Kalinin desert song is Vida alcohol test
protocol they guessed Wiggins if song on
the onion Amin on texture Linda for FIFA
keep this island against protocol
NASA's mystified armistice photo coil
dammit Kenny me via comments next
Pontotoc Assad on the ultra were an
actor LST mannahatta Kahuna's fiance
statistic chefs autumn in mission and
Rolanda enjoyed mo cotton and also
violin mastered in McLean and meat and a
Cespedes al Farouq ina spawned on what
Merriman get on kinda blonde cartons
except Tyrion and as Estes pathologist
what she did for me new Europe the
Ritter stuttering Boylan fifty minute
dear colleagues in the last few years we
have seen a sea change in the way
politics and elections are conducted we
may still deliver leaflets knock on
doors and transmit party political
broadcasts on TV but increasingly our
voters are getting their information
online through social media platforms
and cleverly targeted advertising that
takes advantage of ever more effective
algorithms to target them individually
from thousands of miles away it's fair
to say that citizens all over Europe are
at the mercy of anyone with a sinister
agenda and a computer
we're undergoing a quantum leap in our
electoral processes one that eclipses
the advent of the printing press the
newspaper the radio and the television
but the gap between this evolving
technology on one hand and regulation
and legislation on the other has now
become a great digital chasm
both literally and metaphorically the
old rules ceased to apply as our
legislation falls woefully behind
reality the stubborn refusal of
companies such as Facebook to take clear
and decisive action to police their
platforms opens a door into our
elections that any foreign actor can
waltz through unimpeded the proper
regulation of platforms such as Facebook
is not an infringement on freedom of
speech it is our moral duty we must take
stronger action against fake profiles
and accounts we must strengthen the EU
code of conduct on disinformation and we
must reform electoral laws to cater for
the modern era we must investigate the
financing of political parties by the
Kremlin for instance in the UK we know
that Russian oligarchs have paid huge
sums of money to play tennis with Boris
Johnson hostile governments are taking
advantage of the digital space to
interfere in our elections to further
their own political goals with over 50
national regional and local elections
due in Europe before the end of 2020 we
must start taking this threat seriously
those who detest the idea of democracy
and view the messy process of elections
as a charade to shore up their positions
Vladimir Putin chief amongst them pour
millions in economic and human resources
into targeting European voters we have
seen this in the UK France and Spain -
but it's not just Putin who is playing
this sinister game we know that Dominic
Cummings who is advising our own
government spent time in Russia this
must be investigated and there are many
in this house who are here because of
the darling of the US alt right Steve
Bannon there are those within our own
member states who are more than happy to
accept the help of these external actors
in their quest for power I would look at
Nigel Faraj but he hasn't turned up this
week I also look to the Prime Minister
of the United Kingdom who has refused to
disclose a parliamentary report on
Russian interference in the brexit
referendum of 2016 he knows what is in
that report we know what is in that
report but he refuses to release it
because the truth stands in the way of
his personal ambition Boris Johnson
released the Russia report now things
have got so bad that in the UK electoral
campaign the government is now
impersonating fact-checking websites to
spread misinformation
Vladimir would be proud he does
even need to interfere anymore that one
of the oldest political parties in
Europe is willing to do this says much
about how foreign electoral interference
takes root infects our society and
becomes the norm there must be a
parliamentary response to this
unacceptable behavior and there must be
decisive action both in member states
and in Europe and yet politicians have
so far come up short Facebook still
operates as the Trojan horse into our
democracy the time has come for this new
Parliament for this new commission for
this new reality we live in to get
serious if not we will be forever at the
mercy of any authoritarian at a keyboard
I welcome your opinion colleagues and I
hope you sense the same danger that I do
[Applause]
thank you very much
may I ask the colleagues please if they
want to discuss anything to please not
turn the back to the plenary and to
please maybe sit next to each other
hello hello hello because it's still
quite loud it's loud enough that you
can't hear us obviously or me even with
a mic thank you thank you if you would
mind maybe sitting next to each other
and talking to each other quietly that
would be fine thank you
and I'd now give the floor to minister
to polenin for the council members of
the parliament
Jonathan Kennedy once said the ignorance
of one voter in a democracy impairs the
security of all I believe that
maliciously influenced or mislead voters
could pose a similar risk to our
society's evolving malicious
interference and online manipulation
that this risk to our democratic
institutions is real and requires our
constant attention we are therefore
grateful for this new opportunity to
engage with you on this important topic
let me repeat that
our presidencies priority is to make
sustained efforts to raise awareness
increase preparedness and strengthen the
resilience of our democracies to this
information hybrid threats including
foreign interference in our democracies
remains therefore at the top of our
political agenda the presidency has
taken a number of steps in particular a
dedicated and permanent horizontal
working party of the council was created
during the first month of our presidency
it discusses how to strengthen the EU's
capabilities in countering hybrid
threats and to build resilience in the
EU and member states the Mandate of the
group includes election interference and
disinformation campaigns we have
proposed council conclusions to be
adopted in December on complementary
efforts to enhance resilience and
counter hybrid threats building on the
important work done at the EU level in
recent years the conclusions also pay
attention to countering this information
and securing free and fair elections
president honourable members in the last
debate held in this house in September
so broad agreement that foreign
interference and disinformation pose a
major threat to democracy and yield
values without doubt the EU institutions
and the Member States have an important
role to play it's in the remit of their
competences in the protection of
democratic processes it is therefore
appropriate that protecting European
democracy is also a priority for
President Ron de Lyonne we have in
particular noted with great interest at
vice president Europa will be
responsible for coordinating the work on
a Europe and democracy action plan that
will include a set of initiatives this
require a focus on building up
resilience and countering this
information while pursuing and
protecting fundamental freedoms
countering hybrid threats requires a
comprehensive approach and a horizontal
working method this is why the work
needs to be done in close alignment with
all relevant stakeholders in the EU
institutions as well as in the Member
States to enhance the EU's ability to
prevent detect and respond to hybrid
threats protection of our democracies
and elections involves concerted efforts
by the EU and the Member States but also
the civil society and industry our
response has to be comprehensive with
the focus on both the internal and
external dimensions of the threat and
ladies and that much has been done
already both by the EU institutions and
individual member states let me just
briefly mention the main milestones such
as regular exchanges in the European
election cooperation network setting up
of the rapid alert system enhancement of
strategic communication facilitating
networks of independent fact checkers
promotion of media and digital literacy
and awareness-raising activities and
monitoring of the implementation of the
code of practice by social media
platforms but it is also important that
we further develop institutional
mechanisms and tools to fulfill the
objectives set by the European Council
it is also essential to continue
developing partnerships especially our
cooperation with NATO in this regard the
Helsinki European center of excellence
for countering hybrid threats also
contributes to fostering cooperation in
this field likewise these information
strategies by foreign actors are
deployed beyond our borders so we need
to work with partners in the eastern and
southern neighbourhood and in the
Western Balkans as stressed in the
conclusions on democracy adopted by the
council last month exposing this
information
effective scrutiny over the financing of
political messaging strengthening media
information and digital literacy skills
are key elements in this regard we need
to act together in a structured and
coordinated way in order to tackle these
challenges protecting elections is at
the core of defending our European
values thank you very much
forum president astone Thank You Shane I
think this ahead honest thoughtful
Commission meeting had system repulsion
servile become a sovereign yoga madam
president honourable members thank you
for the opportunity to take the floor on
the issue of interference from other
countries in our democracies and
elections the Commission has been deeply
engaged in broad efforts to address the
manifold risks stemming from lack of
transparency disinformation and other
manipulations of electoral and
democratic processes and is committed to
strengthen this path in the upcoming
term and yes indeed as we heard from the
presidency it will be one of my biggest
tasks in the new commission thank you
for the support the conduct of free and
fair elections is primarily the
responsibility of member states
nevertheless a European approach is
necessary given the cross-border
dimension of efforts to manipulate
democracy and the importance of joining
efforts to address the threats just as
with the rule of law what effects one
member state can affect all and impact
the Union itself the threats at stake
are complex and the targets are
constantly evolving
for instance external actors are more
often using domestic proxies we also see
new technological developments allowing
for new forms and strategies of
interference in the context of 2019
elections
the Commission has taken a number of
concrete steps to address the challenges
including with the election package of
measures to secure free and fair
elections in Europe the code of practice
against this information which has been
signed by Facebook Twitter Google and
Microsoft also we did some progress with
the action plan on this information and
we will build on this work in the
upcoming term we have worked to put a
holistic and permanent framework in
place with an aim to strengthen the
resilience of our democracies and adapt
to the evolving threats and coordinated
and intentional manipulation to address
the threats at stake a coordinated and
comprehensive approach is necessary
involving all actors across government
including regulatory and enforcement
authorities political parties
journalists fact checkers researchers
educators and society and civil society
at large as well as industry and the
online platforms some of them I
mentioned but of course we need to
invite more to work with us and of
course we will need your citizens to
work on strengthening their own
resilience against these new threats I
sometimes say that we have to work on
increasing the demand for truth and this
will be a very big task ahead of us we
need to get better when it comes to
detecting analyzing and exposing this
information and other manipulations of
European democratic processes whatever
the tactics and actors employed this
needs to go hand in hand with wider
efforts on monitoring cybersecurity and
resilience against hybrid threats in
terms of cooperation we can be pleased
with the European cooperation Network on
elections which meets today for the
fifth time to discuss its future work on
safeguarding
elections this is a new crop and a very
important piece of our toolkit also we
need to further enhance cooperation
between EU institutions and EU Member
States via this Network and the rapid
our system which will help us build a
genuine community of practitioners it
will also allow us to build meaningful
cooperation with international partners
such as the g7 or NATO and what we are
facing as because we are facing a real
global problem we can improve the
effectiveness of communications through
a coordinated response to this
information incidents as well as raising
public awareness more generally to this
end it is important to pursue our
efforts aimed at facilitating the
establishment of an independent
community of fact checker and academic
researchers to detect and expose this
information campaigns across social
networks following its initial 12-month
period of implementation the code of
practice on this information is now in
the process of being evaluated shoot the
results under the coat proof
unsatisfactory the commission make
proposed further measures including of a
regulatory nature we also need to invest
in strengthening media literacy which is
key to resilient democratic societies
citizens must be empowered to have the
adequate tools for a well-informed
participation in democratic processes
president-elect for then prayer lion has
proposed a new digital services act
which will upgrade our liability and
safety rules for digital platforms
services and products she has also
pledged to put forward a coordinated
European approach on artificial
intelligence these efforts will be vital
if we are to ensure a prosperous safe
and democratic digital future for Europe
building on the political guidelines of
an electron der Leyen I will in the new
commission lead on the works towards
European democracy action plan
addressing the threat of interference in
our European elections whilst being
mindful of the need to protect the
freedom of expression I will look into
possible legislative proposals to ensure
clearer rules on the financing of
political European political parties and
greater transparency on paid political
advertising in our actions we must never
lose the balance our goal is to protect
our European democracy so it is clear
that the respect for freedom of speech
and of our fundamental rights and values
must be our corn stones thank you very
much have this man for commissary annual
known ahead mrs. Filipov act soon dear
colleague around sheltered spot fear I
mean